I told you this was a tough quiz because we hadn't actually done this before.
So hopefully you were able to find it on the documentation page or
on the internet somewhere.
And so the way that you get the coefficients of a Lasso regression or
of any regression really is by calling .coef_ on
your regression, which in our case just has the name regression.
So if you call this print statement, it's going to give you a list that
contains all of the coefficients that have been found by your regression.
So you can look at this list now, and you can figure out which features have
the large coefficients, which means they're important features, and
which ones have the coefficients that are set to very small values.